en fait cette armée russe ressemble plus
à une non armée russe qui a une armée
russe je pense que le plus puissant de
la marine de l'armée russe et la marine
russe et la marine russe n'a pas été
engagée pour plein de raisons parce que
j'ai craignant pas de marine l'armée de
l'air russe et puissante et spatiale
sont puissantes mais elles ne sont pas
entraînées n'ont pas d'heure de vol
elles ne sont pas suffisamment
modernisées ils n'ont pas de mission de
précision les Russes comme les Chinois
connaissent la doctrine occidentale et
ils essaient de la repiquer dans la
repliquer dans le document dans leur
doctrine mais malheureusement ils n'ont
pas la technique ils n'ont pas les
moyens de faire la gagne centrale pas la
façon dont les Occidentaux s'entraînent
l'armée russe a plein de problèmes des
problèmes qui sont liés à sa nature même
à son fonctionnement à la corruption qui
mine l'armée russe qui a miné l'armée
russe depuis 30 ans au clientélisme à
tout ce système
russe qui a un système
mafieux politique et qui commence par
Poutine et qui va jusqu'en bas
donc violence corruption manque
d'entraînement il y a sans doute des
pépites dans la mer russe toute la
Marius n'est pas n'est pas uniforme mais
elle n'est pas prête à faire la guerre
la seule guerre qu'on l'a vu faire c'est
en Afghanistan on a dû commencer à se
terminer alors c'est pas forcément la
faute des Russes on peut pas plus
mauvais que les que les Américains c'est
c'est simplement qu'il ne s'entraîne pas
la seule guerre qu'ils ont fait de
sérieuse c'est la Syrie et en Syrie bah
on mettait des bons admets des
stratégiques et ils m'ont parlé tout le
monde et après on envoyait les soldats
de cadiro faire la police et garder les
grandes prisonniers voilà et on mettait
les Forces Spéciales donc en fait voilà
la question de l'entraînement la
création de la du bon concept de la
préparation des bons équipements c'est
ça qui est clé on peut dire que les
Occidentaux savent le faire on a la
bonne doctrine le bon concept les bons
niveaux d'entraînement on sait
travailler entre tous les différents
militaires amers la russes ne sert pas
on est capable de faire
l'OTAN la France avec des sources de
commande en français on est capable de
gérer des sorties plusieurs sorties
d'avions de centaines d'avions par jour
pendant des semaines pour une campagne
aérienne les Russes n'ont pas sceptiques
ils ont pas les outils de planification
pour faire ça donc toutes ces
déficiences et en fait tout le système
le système russe dans lequel tout le
monde ment à tout le monde donc les
militaires romantiques et la vérité
c'est le combat la vérité c'est le jour
où il faut y aller c'est là que ce jeune
armée et c'est là que l'armée russe
était jugé et que paradoxalement l'armée